sue présentement dans l'âge idéal dans
le moment idéal de magie marie josée
lord vient d'entrer dans la quarantaine
et cette nouvelle décennie lui fait se
poser beaucoup de questions sur sa vie
de femme
des questions qui trouvent leur écho
dans son nouvel album
[Musique]
je voulais aborder quatre thèmes à
travers ses personnages
quatre thèmes de réflexion qui était
l'amour
plusieurs sortes d'amour la vie et la
mort parce que ça se côtoient et la peur
de vieillir
[Musique]
cet album résonne également dans la
foulée du mouvement moi aussi et des
révélations qui ont éclaboussé l'univers
de la musique classique
marie josée lord crois que ce mouvement
va donner aux artistes
le droit de dénoncer plus rapidement et
plus souvent des situations
inacceptables
c'est à ce niveau là qui va avoir un
plus gros changement c'est à dire de
savoir que tu as le droit de parler et
d'écrire quand c'est pas conforme à teva
leur camp quand c'est pas compter plus
en sécurité quand tu es plus bien dans
une situation c'est un droit qui doit
être établi
[Rires]
[Musique]
la soprano dit être maintenant en totale
harmonie avec sa voix avec ceux donc qui
lui a été révélée alors qu'elle avait
vingt ans après 15 ans de carrière au
canada
elle espère maintenant partir chanter
sur les plus grandes scènes du monde
j'aimerais ça que ça se fasse dans les
dix prochaines années parce que je suis
vraiment là haut au point où ma voix
elle est prête à accueillir c'est à dire
que les murs
ll est mature elle est solide
en attendant d'atteindre cet objectif
elle lance femme son quatrième disque
qu'elle qualifie d' album de la maturité
pour moment où j'ai fait cet album j'ai
tout réglé avec mon passé je vis dans
mon présent et je je je planifie mon
futur
ici catherine françois radio canada
montréal
[Musique]